>> Stephanie Marcus: Good
morning, I'm Stephanie Marcus
from the Science, Technology,
and Business Division
here at the library.
Welcome to our lecture today.
We're going to come
back to the home planet.
And today we have
Dr. Tom Neumann,
who's the deputy
project scientist
for the ICESat-2 Mission.
So we got the right guy.
And he's accompanied by Adriana,
one of his assistants
today, so welcome to her.
Dr. Neumann taught at
the University of Vermont
and did some ice and snow
projects that were funded
by the National Science
Foundation and NASA.
And then he came
to NASA in 2008.
He got his BA in Geophysical
Science from the University
of Chicago and a
Ph.D. in Geophysics
from the University
of Washington.
He's spent a good deal
of time in the cryosphere
and somewhat recently,
made a 470 mile trek
across Antarctica
with three others.
I've read that he
also plays guitar
with other ice scientists, so
that sounds very interesting.
[laughter] And [laughs] I
do hope he flavors his talk
with some tidbits about the
expeditions and the ice band.
I'm also happy to announce
that Dr. Neumann did some
research here at the Library
of Congress a while back,
so please help me welcome
him back to the library.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: Great.
Thank you much.
I did, in fact, come
to do some research.
When I was at Vermont, I was
there from 2001 to about 2008,
and their geology program
there is pretty small.
I was in the geology department,
and I was the only ice person.
[laughter] So I mean, the
number of journals they had,
things weren't online as
readily as they are now,
and so I would put
together a list
of articles I just
couldn't find anywhere else.
And I had a brother who
lived in Alexandria.
I'd come to visit a day early,
and I'd spend the day --
spend the day getting articles.
It was -- yeah, it was awesome.
It's sort of funny that
I had my little Library
of Congress library card,
and I'd tell people,
I went to the Library
of Congress.
They're like, is
that a real library?
I'm like, it's an -- [laughter]
It's an unbelievable library.
You can get anything
you want there.
[laughter] Journals
from anything.
But mostly what I'm
going to talk
about today is not the ice band.
I'll maybe touch on it at the
end if people are interested.
And I do have some
field pictures.
But most of what I'm going
to talk about is ICESat-2.
That's the project I work on.
NASA has just recently
launched two missions
to study the cryosphere,
ICESat-2,
and the other one
being GRACE-Follow-On.
I'll talk just a bit
about GRACE-Follow-On.
But mostly you'll
hear about ICESat-2,
since that's what I know best.
So the polar regions.
We use words like the "polar
regions of the cryosphere,"
so I wanted to just have a
couple slides at the beginning
to put us all in the same page
about what we're talking about.
There's two main pieces
to the cryosphere.
Once is glaciers and ice sheets,
and they're formed
by accumulating snow.
It's so cold in Antarctica
and Greenland
that it rarely melts very much,
and so snow just
accumulated year after year,
decade after decade,
thousands of years at a time.
It doesn't snow very
much down there.
It's a polar desert.
But it doesn't melt,
so it just builds up.
These ice sheets can
be 4,000 meters thick.
You might have heard about
ice coring projects that drill
down through the ice sheets
to collect ice that fell
as snow tens of thousands
or hundreds
of thousands of years ago.
That's the kind of
place they come from.
They move.
They move really slowly though.
They deform under gravity,
just like pancake batter.
When you pour it on the pan,
it kind of slides
out towards the edge.
But they don't move
very quickly.
In the middle of the ice sheet,
it might move just a few
meters a year, sometimes less.
They lose mass.
So they gain mass by snow fall.
They lose mass by
generally calving icebergs
at the edges of Antarctica.
Whenever there's a big one, it
always seems to make the news.
Recently there was a square
one somebody took a picture of,
and so we got phone calls
about, what do you think
about this square iceberg.
And I'm like, it's square?
I mean, what do you
want me to say?
[laughter] It's a
thing that happens.
In Greenland, it's warmer,
so actually about half
of the mass lost
there is due to melt.
So the iceberg that sank the
Titanic almost certainly came
from Greenland, and
it does calve,
but it also melts
quite a lot down there.
The other main piece
of the cryosphere we'll
talk about is sea ice.
Now, sea ice is different
than glaciers or ice sheets.
Sea ice is formed by
freezing of ocean water.
So the air temperature
gets cold, that will freeze
that top layer of water,
just like you might see a
frozen lake or a frozen pond.
But in the ocean, it's
much more dynamic.
There's tides, there's
wind, there's waves.
And so the sea ice moves
around quite a lot.
It's much thinner than glaciers.
It only, at its maximum, gets up
to about 20 meters or so thick.
In the upper left, you can see
there's some really freshly
formed sea ice and
the wind has caused it
to raft on top of each other.
You see -- if I can get
my pointer going here --
see areas where it's
overlapping.
You see places where there's
open water between it.
And if that sea ice is
allowed to continue to grow,
it'll start to collect
snow fall on top of it,
and so that surface will turn
from a dark or translucent
to a bright white, as it
collects snow on top of it.
Sea ice melts seasonally.
When the weather gets warm
in the Artic or Antarctic,
sea ice extent shrinks and then
it grows again the next fall
and winter.
And it pretty much forms --
well, anywhere it's cold enough
to freeze the water, so places
like Hudson Bay get sea ice.
A few years ago, the Great Lakes
froze over almost entirely.
Of course, they're freshwater,
so they have a different
freezing point.
But around the Arctic Ocean and
around the Antarctic continent,
you get sea ice annually.
So those are the two terms
I'm going to end up using
that I wanted to
make sure I defined.
So why is NASA interested
in these kind of areas?
You might know that places
like Greenland are losing mass.
The Greenland ice sheet
is getting smaller.
And what we've learned over the
last 10 years or so is that most
of that mass lost from Greenland
or from Antarctica
is concentrated
at the edges of the ice sheet.
Now, it turns out
these are the places
where ocean interacts
with the ice sheets.
These glaciers tend to terminate
in water, in the ocean water.
So as ocean water gets
just a little bit warmer,
that's a large amount
of heat that's available
for melting more ice.
So this is a map of Greenland
and where we've seen
changes there.
In Antarctic, here's
a time series
from a mission called "GRACE."
And what GRACE does is it
measures the mass change
of the whole ice sheet,
and I'll talk about that
in a little more detail.
But the take-away here
is that through time --
so you can see time
marching forward here --
you can look at the record of
mass loss measured by GRACE.
Most of the loss is
here in West Antarctica.
You might have heard about
places like Pine Island Glacier
or Thwaites Glacier
that are losing mass.
And that's a place where
the ocean water contacts the
ice sheet.
So as that ocean water
warms just a little bit,
it has a big impact
on the ice sheet.
So this place over here
is called West Antarctica.
This little thumb
is the peninsula.
And the bigger piece
here is East Antarctica.
East Antarctica is probably
three-quarters or so
of the total amount
of ice in Antarctica.
And it doesn't change nearly as
quickly as West Antarctica does.
So that's one reason
why NASA is interested,
because these ice
sheets are changing
and they're losing mass,
and that mass, that water,
when it leaves the ice
sheet, it just goes back
into the world's oceans.
And that's one of
the main contributors
to global sea level rise.
You took ice that used to be
sitting on rock in Antarctica
or Greenland, you put the
ice cubes back in the water,
and they're going
to raise sea level.
So that's one of the main
reasons NASA's interested.
For sea ice, if I can
get this guy to play.
We talked about how sea
ice is pretty dynamic.
And in this animation, you
see time marching past up here
in the upper left,
and these are images
of the sea ice extent
in the Arctic Ocean.
You can see Greenland over here,
Alaska over here, Canada here.
And this should give you a sense
for just how dynamic
that sea ice is.
It grows and shrinks annually,
and when storms come through,
it moves it quite a lot.
You can see it generally tends
to form over in this part
of the basin and is lost
right down the coast
of Greenland over here.
You also lose some
over in this area.
And we've been able to take
pictures of sea ice extent
from imagers, since about 1979.
So that's how we put
together this time series
of how the extent
has been changing.
Now, one of the things
we're really interested
in is how the thickness
of sea ice changes.
Really thick sea ice,
it's hard to break up.
It lasts much longer
than very thin sea ice.
If it's first-year sea ice,
you have a storm come through,
it can break up that ice.
And what happens when
you lose sea ice is
that it increases
the transfer of heat
from the ocean to
the atmosphere.
And you say, all right, well,
why would we care about that?
It turns out that the
exchange of heat from the ocean
to the atmosphere in the
Arctic is one of the big things
that drives climate patterns
and weather patterns
around the world.
Things like the jet stream
position is influenced
by the heat exchange up here.
Whether we have a snowier winter
here in D.C. is determined,
in part, by the state of
the sea ice in the Arctic.
So that's really a driver
for weather patterns
around the world.
So the more we can understand
about how it grows in shrinks,
including the thickness,
the better.
Oop -- and I'm going
to go to the next one.
There we go.
So if we just look at the area
of Arctic sea ice in September
of every year, we can
make a time series
for how the extent has changed.
We've picked September because
that's basically the end
of the summer season
in the Arctic.
You get into October, it gets
cold, sea ice starts to regrow.
So what we're looking
at here is a graph
of the minimum sea ice
extent in the Arctic.
It's usually about the
second week of September.
And what you can see is
that since 1979 here,
it was kind of flat
for a most of the '80s,
but you get into the '90s
and you get bigger
and bigger changes.
And now we're -- oop.
I should put the new one in.
Now we're out here in 2016,
there's actually two more
data points on there.
It's a lot smaller than
it was back in the '80s.
And remember, this
is the extent.
This doesn't tell us
anything about the thickness
or the stability of it.
It's just how much was there.
The mission I work on is called
ICESat-2 and it's designed
to measure that thickness
of the sea ice.
In the Antarctic, the
seas around the Antarctic,
the changes are much
more subtle.
The graph up here is the
change in the Arctic,
which we just saw a moment ago.
For the Antarctic,
it's pretty flat.
It might be increasing
a little bit.
You can see there's
been this change
in about the last
four or five years.
It's hard to know if
that's something permanent
or short-term.
But at least since the early
'80s, since 1980 or so,
Antarctic extent has
been pretty flat.
The Arctic has been losing
sea ice area over time.
So that's why NASA's interested.
One of their mandates is
to understand the
planet we live on, Earth,
and the cryosphere is
a big piece of that.
So as I mentioned, we
have two new missions
to study the cryosphere.
GRACE-Follow-On, its launch
is up here in the upper left,
launched in May of this year.
And the mission I work on,
ICESat-2, just launched about --
not even two months ago.
We launched in the
early morning hours,
so we had a really nice
view of the rocket.
GRACE-Follow-On launched
in the afternoon.
Both from the West Coast,
Vandenberg Air Force
Base out in California.
So GRACE-Follow-On.
As you might imagine
from the name,
there was an original
mission called GRACE.
We saw some of its data earlier.
This is the Follow-On
mission to that.
And GRACE and GRACE-Follow-On
are composed of two satellites.
You can see the one
in the foreground,
and there's another one way
off here in the background.
And what the mission does
is it measures the distance
between those two
satellites very accurately.
It uses microwave
ranging between them.
So it can range to better a
millimeter how far apart these
two satellites are.
And the way it works is that
as the lead satellite goes
over a place in the earth
that has relatively more mass
or less mass, it experiences
a slight acceleration
and it moves a little
farther away
from the trailing satellite.
Now, when the trailing
satellite gets up to that place
where there's a little more
mass, it also accelerates,
and so the distance
between the two is a measure
of how much mass difference
there is in the earth.
So over Antarctica, when the
Antarctic ice sheet is losing
mass, we compile data
from many passes of GRACE
over the same places in
Antarctica to determine,
is it gaining mass
or is it losing mass?
Is the front satellite
accelerating just a little bit
more than it was last time,
or maybe a little less
than it was last time?
GRACE was mainly designed to
study the hydrologic cycle.
It can do things like
measure aquifers.
Are we losing water out of
aquifers or are we gaining it?
Is there more mass here,
is there less mass here?
It can measure changes
in seasonal snow,
which is totally cool, because
you get a big snowfall here
and you could measure
that in GRACE data.
So what GRACE is doing
is measuring mass
changes primarily.
Given that, it's on orbit 350
kilometers above the surface
of the earth and these two
satellites are hundreds
of kilometers apart.
You end up with a pretty low
spatial resolution measurement.
And what I mean by that is you
can measure mass changes really
accurately, but only an average
over hundreds of
square kilometers.
So it's an average
over a big area.
However, given its orbit, you
get a lot of data through time.
So you can get a data
point over a place
about once a month,
which is great.
We saw that time series earlier
of mass change in Antarctica
from GRACE and that was a data
point about once every month.
GRACE and GRACE-Follow-On are
by NASA's Jet Propulsion Lab
out in Pasadena, California,
and that's all I'm going to say
about GRACE, because I work at
one of the other NASA centers,
right out here in Maryland,
NASA's Goddard Space
Flight Center.
And we recently launched
ICESat-2.
Now, at ICESat-2, as you might
imagine, is also a follow-on.
There was a first
ICESat mission,
although it'd be pretty bold
to name your first mission
ICESat-2, just to mix it
up and confuse people.
[laughter] We didn't do that.
ICESat-2 is a laser altimeter,
so it has a laser on board.
And what it does is it sends out
a small pulse of laser light,
and it times, super accurately,
how long it takes that light
to go from the space craft
to the earth and back again.
So that's essentially a range.
And what it does with that
is we reconstruct elevation
of the earth's surface.
We do that by taking that time,
how long did it take to go
from space craft to the
earth and back again,
figuring out where we were
pointing or am I pointing
at the wall over here?
Am I pointing at
the wall over there?
And where are we in the orbit?
You put those three
pieces together
and you can measure the height
of anything you fly over,
just by bouncing
these laser beams off.
The footprint size of the
laser beam on the ground is
about 17 meters, so sort
of the size of this room.
So we get really
detailed information.
We can measure the height of
something about this size.
Whereas GRACE was over
hundreds of square kilometers,
we're measuring meter scale.
However, we have fairly
low resolution temporally.
We've got these little
spots on the ground,
and our orbit repeats
about every 91 days.
So we can see about times a
year how a particular place
is changing.
Together, these two
missions, GRACE-Follow-On
and ICESat-2 are
really complimentary.
One gives you great
time resolution,
the other gives you
great spatial resolution.
You put those two things
together, you we should be able
to learn more about how ice
sheets and sea ice are changing
than we've ever been
able to before.
So I'm going to walk you
through a little bit more
about how ICESat-2 works.
The main instrument on
here is called the lidar.
That's the thing that
generates the laser light.
And the time it takes to go
from space craft to ground
and back again, we call
a range measurement.
It's essentially a distance.
The other piece we need
is the pointing angle.
Are we pointing straight down?
Are we a little left?
Are we a little right?
And then the last piece is
where are we in the orbit?
Are we over Maryland
or are we over Canada,
or are we over Greenland?
And we figure that out with GPS,
just like you would
in your phone.
Certainly, these are
much fancier GPSs
and give us much
more accurate data
than you would get from a phone.
But basically, you take these
three pieces: pointing angle,
range measurement, space
craft altitude, and you figure
out the height of the earth.
If you measure that height at
the same place through time,
you can tell, is it getting
higher or is it getting lower?
From the vantage point of space,
you can see how ice
sheets are changing,
how sea ice is changing, oceans,
deserts, forests, all of it,
which is totally cool.
A couple of slides
about technical details,
in case anybody is interested.
The laser on ICESat-2 fires
10,000 shots a second,
which is an incredibly
fast repetition rate.
And it sends out really small
pulses of light, so micropulses,
we would call them, in each
of six beams simultaneously.
That's the multibeam
part of it there.
And the way it does its
detection and its measurement,
it sends out these light pulses
of light 10,000 times a second,
and it's actually
detecting individual photons
as they come back.
So we have super
sensitive detectors on board
for each of those six spots.
So people say, oh, you know,
could I see the laser
light from the space craft?
Probably not, because they're
so low energy and the number
of photons that we're detecting
on the way back from each
of these shots is
kind of 1, 2, 3, 4.
It's really small number
of photons coming back in,
but that's the basis
of our measurement.
With this super fast firing
laser and our altitude,
we get a footprint
that's about 17 meters
in diameter every 70 centimeters
along each of those 6 beams.
So the footprint from one shot
to the next overlaps the
previous one by about 95%.
So we end up with
continuous coverage
in the along-track direction.
It's a tremendous
amount of data.
And it's a very NASA way of
measuring things, you know?
It's a laser in space,
10,000 times a second,
counting individual photons.
It's kind of crazy.
And the cool thing is, is that
later in the presentation,
I'll be able to show
you what some
of our early data looks like.
We've been on orbit now
for about six weeks.
We're still in calibration
phase,
but it's astounding
what you can see
with this kind of instrument.
The last slide about
technical details is here.
If you were able to see each of
these six spots on the ground,
you'd see that we've arranged
them in a rectangular pattern,
so that as the beams are
described on the surface
of the earth, we have
these beam pairs.
We have two beams right
next to each other,
separated by about 90 meters.
And what that does for us is it
lets us measure the elevation
in the along-track
direction, sure.
But it also lets us
measure the slope
in the across-track direction.
Is this one higher than
that one, or vice versa?
And it turns out that's
a key piece in figuring
out how ice sheet
elevations are changing.
So we have six beams
arranged in three beam pairs.
And if anybody's interested in
what wavelength we're using,
it's a bright green
light, 532 nanometers.
We split it into
six beams, and yeah,
we're detecting individual
photons as they come in.
I realize that for folks
who don't work on this kind
of thing, it all sounds
a little bit esoteric.
So we actually have a
little animation that --
that really brings it home,
what this is all about.
So let's see if I can
get this thing to play.
Doo-doo-doo.
[music] This is perfect
for management level.
[murmuring animation sounds]
>> No, no, no, no, no!
>> Attention, photons.
Prepare to measure
Earth's changing ice.
[music] [inaudible] pulse 22A4.
In 5...4...
[inaudible] [music] 3...2...
ONE! [whirring sound] [music]
>> Dr. Tom Neumann:
There you go.
>> [video] WEEE!
WEE! [shouts of excitement]
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: Laser light
comes out, tons of photons,
down towards the earth.
[video] [photons
murmuring excitedly]
[music]
>> Dr. Tom Neumann:
Couple of them make it
down to the earth's surface
and bounce back towards
the space craft.
>> [video] Weeeee!
[ Music ]
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: Turns
out photons get discouraged,
you know.
[laughter] It's a long way.
[laughter]
[photon gasps]
[ Triumphant Music ]
[ Laughter ]
>> Whoa! [laughter]
[ Triumphant Music ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Music ]
>> [video] Excellent job, pho.
Your travel time
has been recorded.
[music] Let's see the
data elevation dataset.
Ready the next group!
[music] [laughter]
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: You know,
it's a little tongue-in-cheek,
but it really is the
basis of how this works.
We send out a whole
bunch of photons,
we're detecting just one
or two on the way back
and recording their travel time.
And Adriana's here,
and she was the lead --
one of the leads on
putting this one together,
of coming up with a way to
explain how a laser altimeter
in space lets you
measure height.
That's actually how it happens.
[music] Except photons
don't get discouraged.
[laughter] They do
wear sunglasses though.
I've seen them up close.
[ Laughter ]
So ICESat-2 is in orbit now.
Our orbit takes us up to
88 degrees north and down
to 88 degrees south,
and we do about 15 laps
of the planet every day.
Can you guys see this okay?
From my perspective, it's
a little bit washed out,
but you can see it cruising
around the planet there.
You'll notice there's lots
of clouds on Earth, right?
You go outside, maybe
it's a sunny day,
maybe it's a cloudy day.
We're using really low
energy visible green light.
So on a cloudy day,
we're mostly going
to measure the tops
of the clouds.
The light will bounce
off the clouds.
You might have seen
that in the last video,
where some of the
photons got scattered
by the clouds or bounced back.
They didn't make it all
the way to the ground.
But places where we
have a clear sky view,
we'll detect photons coming back
from the surface of the earth.
We're called ICESat-2 so the
instrument really is optimized
to measure changes in sea ice
and in glaciers and ice sheets.
But from space, as
I mentioned earlier,
we really do get a
measurement of everything.
We'll get lots of
data over the oceans.
We'll get lots of data
over land, over cities.
And we have data products that
cover each one of those things.
The data product I work on,
the goal of that product is
to generate unique latitude,
longitude, and elevation
for each photon that we detect.
So with a laser firing
10,000 times a second,
six beams at the same time,
order of about five
photons coming back,
something like that.
So one way to think about it
is that in the time it takes
to blink about half a second,
ICESat-2 will do on the order
of about 15 or 20,000 individual
measurements of photons.
So it's a tremendous
amount of data.
The laser is on 24/7.
It's on all the time,
collecting data.
So these data products are big.
If you're interested
in ice sheet elevation
and ice sheet elevation
exchange,
you probably don't want
to deal with, you know,
billions of individual photons.
You're going to average
those together.
Or similarly, if you're
interested in tree height,
you don't want to deal with
things at the photon level.
The data sets are
simply too big.
So what the higher
level products do is
to aggregate those
photons together.
Maybe they'll take 40 meters
or so worth of photons
or 100 meters worth of photons,
average those heights together
to come up with one
elevation measurement
that has much better
precision than a single photon.
So I'm going to -- we
watched that one already.
Oops. So what does the
data actually look like,
if you're going to look at it?
So we talked about how it's
detecting individual photons,
right?
And we're assigning an
individual latitude,
longitude, and height.
This turns out what you
would see if you plot it.
We have elevation along the
y-axis, and all of these plots,
and either time or
distance along the x-axis.
And this is for data
for a single beam.
You see each one of
these little blue dots?
That's a photon that
ICESat-2 detected
and sent the information back
to the earth, and we assign
that latitude, longitude,
and height.
Now you see there's a lot of
speckle in these random dots.
We use green laser light, but
it turns out the sun also puts
out light in the green
part of the spectrum.
So that's background
light from the sun.
At nighttime, you
don't see any of that.
In the daytime, this
is about what you see.
And the photons that are
reflected off the surface are
this bright blue line
that jumps out at you.
That line is actually
composed of millions of tiny --
of individual photons that
we detected and located.
So your problem then
becomes, if you're interested
in the ice sheet's surface,
is figuring out exactly what
the elevation of this line is.
So that's why they're
doing averages
and combining lots
of photon data.
With just a single photon,
let's say this one, I can't tell
if it's a background photon
or is it a signal photon
that I'm interested
in off the surface?
But your eye just naturally
aggregates photons together
and it's just drawn to
this bright blue line.
It turns out this is real
data from space collected
about two weeks ago
over Antarctica.
And the next couple slides
will show some of the data
over different surface types
to show you what
the data looks like.
But each one of the slides
will be basically the same.
Elevation along one
axis and time
or distance along the other.
You can think of it as, like,
a line across the stage here,
and you're looking
at it in side view.
So up above is higher elevation.
This is the sky and the
space craft up here.
Down below is the
center of the earth.
Does that view make
sense to folks?
Each of these dots?
Yeah, okay.
Cool. So we take data
over ocean, right?
Here's a track that
went over the Atlantic,
just off of the coast of
the U.S. You can see Maine
over here, Canada over there.
And we have elevation
along this axis.
Here's about four and a half
kilometers on that axis.
And it looks really kind
of lumpy through there.
But it turns out if you
zoom in a little bit,
what we're doing is we're
detecting individual
ocean swells.
[audience murmurs] The
height of this is --
these ticks are two
meters apart.
So these things are kind
of four meters high are so,
about 700 meters along-track.
So that's four meters of relief
in each one of these waves
or swells that are tens or
hundreds of meters long.
So wavelengths in
this picture are
about on the order
of 140 meters.
You see there's relatively
little background light,
so the sun was pretty low in
the sky when we took this pass.
But that's pretty cool.
But yeah. This is
all data from space.
We had simulated data
ahead of time to work
on this, that, or the other.
This is real data.
It's mind boggling to me in
some ways how well it's working
and the cool things you can see.
Here's some data over
Russia, a forest in Siberia.
You see all this
background light.
This is daytime data.
Certainly, you can see
these blurry things here
at the surface.
Those are returns off of trees.
What you see is this
bright line underneath,
that's the ground
beneath the trees.
And some photons are being
reflected off the top
of the canopy, some off
the middle of the canopy.
So we can use ICESat-2
data to figure
out tree heights
around the world.
We take this height, compare it
with the height of the earth,
and there's your tree height.
Here's a little blow up
of that scene right there,
and you can see these trees
are kind of on the order of,
oh, 15, 20 meters high.
So they're pretty big trees.
They're kind of 60
foot tall trees.
You can also see a break
in the canopy right here,
either a road cut or a
stream or that sort of thing.
Here's an image from Google
Earth with our tracks on here.
And then here's the little
road we're crossing right
down there at the bottom.
So that's pretty astounding.
And we haven't even got
to the good stuff yet.
[laughter]
Here's a track coming
off of Mexico
into the Pacific Ocean
from left to right.
Again, elevation on this
axis, distance on that axis.
We're coming down the
forested hillside.
You can see the trees, just
like we saw in the last picture.
And then we cross
over into this lagoon.
You get a bright
return off the surface,
but some of that green
light is actually getting
down into the water, and
we're picking up the bottom
of the lagoon, as well.
You can measure depth of water
up to some distance
with this data.
Compare the surface with
the bottom and you can say,
all right, well that's
about four meters deep,
which is totally cool.
You go across a little
shawl right here
and you can see these
individual waves in the ocean.
The water in the lagoon is nice
and still, as you'd expect.
And you get ocean
waves, as we saw earlier.
Here's another scene
from Mexico.
We have the Gulf of
Mexico over here.
We're getting a lot
more reflections
in the water column here.
It's because the
water is turbid.
There's lots of stuff in the
water reflecting laser light.
A stand of mangrove forests,
and they're interpreting this
as mangroves because you're
getting a really bright return
beneath them, and it's very
flat, which is what you'd expect
from still water under
these kind of trees.
As you move farther
to the right,
you see the ground
elevation starts to vary.
You get hills, you
get little ridges.
So that's more of a
non-flooded forest.
But that's totally cool.
Here's another scene.
This one is off the
coast of Australia.
You see the land, there's
some trees at the coast.
And then the coastline's
right here.
We have the surface of the
water, some ocean waves.
But you look faintly,
you might be able
to see the bathymetry
through here.
So you can tell how
deep the water is.
You can see that there's
a mount right here.
There's another ridge over here.
And that's nine meters worth of
water that we're seeing through.
Further off to the right,
you kind of get some hints
of some other structure
down here,
which is a good 25
meters of water.
That's 75 feet of water.
That's a lot of water
that we're seeing through.
Super excited about it.
So here's one more.
This is the Bikini Atoll, some
really clear Pacific water.
Similar to picture to
what we've seen before.
You've got some ocean waves.
You've got the land right here.
So that's this peak showing up.
And you can see the
edge of the lagoon reef.
This is 30 meters of water.
That's almost 100 feet of
water we're ranging through,
from space, using
individual photons.
That's insane!
It's just crazy.
So when we started
showing this data to some
of the oceanography community,
and they're super excited.
Because measuring
bathymetry close
to coast is a pretty
hard thing to do.
You can't bring ships into
each of these little lagoons
and you can't bring
them close to the coast
so they can map deeper
water more easily
than they can map
shallow water bathymetry.
This is going to be an
awesome tool for them.
So for the cryosphere, we're
designed to do cryosphere.
So all of this is like gravy.
This is all bonus.
We're going to do cool
things for forests,
we're going to do cool
things for oceans.
What we're really interested
in is sea ice and glaciers;
glaciers and ice sheets.
So here's a graphic of how
this works for sea ice.
So we talked about how we can
measure sea ice extent pretty
readily, but we can't measure
the thickness very well.
And this graphic
didn't want to play.
I'm going to try
backing it up again.
Boop! Let's see if
it goes this time.
But yeah, you can measure
the extent with a camera,
but measuring the
thickness is harder.
Getting this graphic
to play is harder yet.
[laughter] Hmm.
I don't know why that
doesn't want to go.
That's goofy.
But actually, we can
just pause it right there
and I can explain it from here.
So we're going along
with our six beams,
we're measuring the height
of everything, right?
So here, you see
some open water.
And here's some sea ice
that's sitting in that water.
Ooh, here you go.
I wonder if I can
pause it right there.
Ooh. Rats.
[laughter] I'm going
to get it yet.
If this is my biggest problem
today, I'm doing pretty well.
So we'll take those
two measurements.
We have the height of the
sea ice and the height
of the water that
it's sitting in.
And somehow it got to
a really good shot.
I'm going to be patient.
Okay, I'm not that patient.
[laughter] But what we do
to measure the sea ice
thickness is just compare those
two heights.
Trying to get a stable picture
that I can actually talk to.
There we go.
Cool. That's perfect.
All right.
So here's a crack
in the sea ice,
where you can see the ocean
water sticking through.
We're getting heights and
elevations of the sea ice
on either side of it, and you
have the ocean water in between.
So for sea ice science,
what we want
to do is compare
those two heights.
That tells us how high
the sea ice is sticking
up out of the water.
The term for that is "free
board," same as a free board
on a boat, if you guys
are sailors at all.
But what it does for sea ice
is since we know it's ice,
we know the density of it, we
know the density of the water,
it lets us estimate the
thickness of that sea ice.
About 10% of sea ice sticks
up out of the ocean water.
So in this case, let's
say the free board
of the sea ice was
about 30 centimeters.
That means the total thickness
of that sea ice is
about 10 times that.
It's about 3 meters.
That lets us get at the
third dimension of sea ice.
We can measure the extent
really readily from cameras,
but getting the thickness has
been a long-standing challenge
for sea ice science.
So with ICESat-2 data
combined with those images,
we really can put together
a three-dimensional picture
of the sea ice in the
Arctic, in the Antarctic,
and how it's changing
through time.
So here's an example of what
data over sea ice look like.
It's a little messier, but
what you end up seeing are all
of these ridges on sea ice.
That's the sea ice elevation.
But can you see these little
flat spots through here?
Those are cracks in the sea ice.
That's where we're ranging down
to the ocean in between them.
So these are really small leads.
Here's a scale bar
for reference.
It's about 70 kilometers, so
this is a long stretch of data
through the Arctic Ocean.
But there's some
larger leads over here
and another big one over there.
So in this case, we have
the ocean water here,
right about zero meters.
And the sea ice here is about --
sticking up by about one meters.
So that's actually really
thick, probably old sea ice.
It's on the order
of ten meters thick,
about ten times what you're
measuring for the free board.
So from a data processing
standpoint, the challenge
of sea ice data is to
separate ocean elevation
from sea ice elevation so
you can do that difference.
Over ice sheets, here's a
stretch from Antarctica.
Here's the Ross Sea down here,
Ross Ice Shelf going
up onto the plateau.
Actually, this one's
going the other way.
It's going from the plateau
down onto the ice sheet.
Elevation-wise, ice
sheets are kind of boring.
They're pretty flat.
They do have some typography
to them, but not like the coast
of Mexico and not like
Australia, and not like sea ice.
So this data often looks
pretty flat at a short scale,
but at a larger scale, you start
to see mountains through there
that we're ranging to.
The blue line is ICESat-2 data.
And this black line
that's on top of it is data
from another lesser satellite
that we won't talk about.
And you can see how this
black line is far inferior
to the super detail we're
getting from ICESat-2.
The data from along the black
curve are totally missing this
value right here, while
we're picking up the bottom
of the valley and the little
peaks in the valley, as well.
So that's totally cool.
Here's another stretch
where there's some crevasses
or cracks in the ice sheet.
These are pretty steep sides on
these things, and we're picking
up the slopes from the top all
the way down to the bottom,
some data off the
bottom and back again.
So we can actually
measure crevasse depth,
as well, which is cool.
What we really want to do though
is take data from ice sheets
from the same place and
compare it through time
to see how it's getting bigger
and how it's getting smaller.
We think with the data
quality we're seeing so far,
we should be able to
resolve elevation changes
of about a centimeter,
from space, using photons.
It's -- I've worked on the
project for about ten years,
and you go through lots of hoops
and reviews and things go well
and things don't go well.
But it's so gratifying to
actually see it on orbit
and collecting data like that.
It's really amazing.
And the data quality has
been just outstanding.
Knock on wood [knocking]
[laughter] Cool.
So ICESat-2 is in orbit now.
Here's the first known
sighting of ICESat-2.
It might be a little
bit hard to see.
One of our colleagues in the
lab, Jeremy, was down in Chile.
He took a look at where we were
supposed to be through time
and he noticed that on
October 25th at about 3:00
in the morning, we were
going to be very close
to where he was in Chile.
And so he set up his
camera on a tripod
on about a 20 second exposure.
And I can't even see
it from my angle,
but there should be a line right
through here and
that's ICESat-2.
That's how you know
it's not fake.
[ Laughter ]
You can go outside and
see it go past, right?
>> Somebody could
draw a line of it.
[ Laughter ]
>> Dr. Tom Neumann:
I encourage you
to take a look at our website.
You can see when we're going
to be in your neighborhood,
and you can look up
at the right time.
And if the sun catches
the solar array,
this is exactly what you'd see.
>> The website is
the heavens-above,
you can see any satellite
going over.
>> Dr. Tom Neumann:
That's right.
And you can just type in
ICESat-2 and it'll tell you
when your next pass is.
Absolutely.
Cool. So the last section I'm
going to talk about is, okay,
great, we're measuring all
these elevations from space.
It's outstanding.
Yada, yada, yada.
How do you know they're right?
How do we compare with
something else to say
that we're getting
the right answer?
So you might have noticed in
the animation of the orbits
that we go up to 88
north and 88 south.
And all of our tracks converge
right at 88 north and 88 south.
It turns out that 88 north,
of course, is in the middle
of the Arctic Ocean, kind
of a tough place to get to.
88 south, ironically enough,
is much easier to get to.
It's pretty close
to the South Pole.
It's about 220 kilometers away.
And you can fly down
to the South Pole.
The U.S. has a research station
right at the center there,
which is what I did
last year in December
with three other colleagues.
And we went out to this area
to measure the elevation
of the ice sheet with GPS.
We flew into South Pole Station,
we took two tract vehicles
and drove out to this 88
south line of latitude
and surveyed the elevation along
this part of the arc right here.
We had two high precision
GPS instruments with us
to create a reference
dataset for ICESat-2.
So when we're getting data
from space, we can compare it
with our GPS data to say,
well, how are we doing?
And having that independent
dataset is a great check
on the data.
All of our tracks converge
around this circle,
so as it turns out, ICESat-2
will survey this little section
at least once a day
and sometimes twice a
day, depending on the day.
The whole circle was too
far around for us to go.
We were cold and
wanted to go home.
[laughter] So we only did
this 300 kilometer stretch.
Actually, that's not true.
It was all part of the plan.
But still.
[laughter] We'll intersect 277
of the tracts, it's about 20%
of the ICESat-2 tracks.
And yeah, we're getting
about one centimeter accuracy
with our GPS survey, so
it's a really solid dataset
to compare with.
There's a campaign,
an airborne campaign,
called Oppression IceBridge
that flies a laser altimeter
from an aircraft, and they've
actually flown this circle
several times.
So we're able to take our
ground data from the pink line,
especially around this 88
south arc, and compare it
with their data from
an airplane,
and then compare the airplane
data to the data from space.
So it's sort of a nested
calibration approach.
We just surveyed this
little 300 kilometers,
but if we use our 300 kilometers
to prove out the aircraft data,
then we can use that
aircraft data to look
at an even larger scale,
all to assess ICESat-2.
So here's what it looks
like when you're cruising
around at 88 south with 3
of your closest friends.
We had tract vehicle here.
We had a big long sled behind us
that had pretty much
everything we needed
for the next couple
weeks we were out there.
We had two of these vehicles.
You guys might be able to see
these yellow blobs on here.
Those are our tents.
We just left them set
up right on the surface.
And this is pretty typical of
what it looks like down there.
It's pretty flat, right?
You see some little
bumps, little ridges here.
These are little
snowdrifts called sastrugi.
But big picture,
it's pretty flat.
If you take a look
at what the --
I think I got to
go forward two --
what the data actually look
like, here's a similar plot
to what we saw before.
Here's elevation on this
axis, distance on that one.
We went over this giant hill.
It was like 300 feet high.
But it was like 100 miles long.
I mean, you would have no idea
that there's a hill there.
It's so subtle.
[laughter] But when you
look at the whole arc,
all the way around 300
kilometers, this is the kind
of typography you see.
It's one of the flattest places
on the ice sheet down there.
The other experiment we left out
there are called corner cubes.
So comparing against our
reference GPS data gives you a
sense of elevation,
how good are we doing
in our elevation measurement.
What these do is let us test
out how we're doing in terms
of assigning a latitude
and a longitude.
There's a little plastic
cap we bought at Home Depot,
drilled a hole in it,
and there's a little
piece of glass in there.
Now, the facets and
the edges on that piece
of glass are optimized
to reflect green light
back to the space craft.
When we put these poles in,
we surveyed the location
of these poles super accurately
with our GPS to be good
to about a centimeter.
And these little
pieces of glass in here,
corner cube retro reflectors,
bounces that light back
to the space craft,
and we should be able
to pick these up in our data.
So we should be able to uniquely
say, oh, this is pole 209,
and our data processing
assigns it a latitude,
a longitude, and an elevation.
But we have an individual
check, an independent check,
on the latitude, the longitude,
and the elevation of about 40
of these little poles
that we left
out in the middle
of the ice sheet.
So the GPS data by itself
lets you check elevation,
but surveying specific known
targets lets you check the
latitude and the
longitude, as well.
Another way you might think
of doing it is hunting
through our data
until you find data
that passes over this building.
We know exactly where
this building is.
We know exactly how high it is.
You can go into the
ICESat-2 data and say, well,
what did ICESat-2 think about
the height of this building
and the location of the
edges of the building.
This is a finer measurement
than using a building,
because this corner
cube is about the size
of your fingernail and
we know its position
to better than a centimeter.
I'm not sure if you
could get positions
of GSA buildings
to a centimeter.
If they have it, they
probably don't give it
out to people, I would guess.
Anyway, so yeah.
That was a nice day to be out
on the ice sheet, blue sky.
Blue on the top.
White on the bottom.
Pretty typical of what
it looks like down there.
Yeah, so for NASA
studying the cryosphere,
the future really is here.
We've got two new missions.
ICESat-2 has a required
lifetime,
design lifetime of three years.
We have fuel on board to go
a whole lot longer than that.
And so far, the data
look really, really good.
GRACE-Follow-On had
some initial hiccoughs
in getting their
systems turned on.
They had to switch from their
A-side instruments to some
of their B-side instruments,
but they started
collecting science data again
about two weeks ago, about
the same time that we did.
And hopefully, they'll get
their processing sorted out
and start putting out
some good data, as well.
Our data from NASA, from both
GRACE-Follow-On and ICESat-2,
freely available to the public.
We have a period where we
do checkout and calibration,
but after that, it
goes to data centers
that are open to the world.
Our data center's
called the National Snow
and Ice Data Center.
You didn't know that we had
one of those, but we do.
[laughter] It's in
Boulder, Colorado,
and if you're interested
in cryospheric data,
like that from ICESat or
ICESat-2, you can get it there.
Anybody can.
Typically the time from date
of data collection to the date
that you can get it at the
data center is about 40 days.
We're still in our
beginning phases.
We just turned the laser on
for the first time 35 days ago.
So but by January, we should be
into pretty normal operations.
And all of you now are
super excited about ICESat-2
and looking at your
house from space.
[laughter] You can do it there.
National Snow and
Ice Data Center.
That's all I had, and I'm happy
to take whatever
questions people have.
Thanks very much for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephanie Marcus: Okay,
the house rule is
you ask the question,
Tom will repeat it
and answer it.
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: Ooh.
>> Stephanie Marcus:
So we get it, you know,
none of this, what did they say?
What did they say?
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: What
did they say, yeah, right.
Please.
>> Audience Member: Thanks.
Thank you very much
for that presentation.
I'm interested also
in other ways
of acquiring ground
[inaudible] or --
and the work that you
actually did are available
to use earlier data from
known points in the Antarctic
and [inaudible] to
check other places?
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: Right, so
the question was, if we're --
if I can paraphrase --
are we able to use data
collected earlier from places
like Greenland or
Antarctica or other places
to check the quality
of the ICESat-2 data?
And the answer is, sometimes.
Greenland and Antarctica
do change through time.
We know that they're changing
especially close to the edges.
If you had data collected from
the middle of the ice sheet,
which is changing
more slowly, then yes,
we probably can use that.
There are places on the earth
that the rock elevation changes
either slowly or in a known way.
You get these steady
uplift or subsidence.
We can use that data as well.
The piece I didn't mention
about our 88 south traverse is
that we'll repeat
that survey every year
that ICESat-2 is on orbit.
So even if that middle part
of the ice sheet is changing,
and it probably is, we should
be able to correct for that.
That part of the ice sheet is
one of the more stable parts.
The elevation change
there should be less
than a centimeter a year.
But we should be able
to correct out for that.
So you could use and you can
use prior data, but you have
to make sure you account for
how the earth has changed
between when the data was
first collected and today.
Yeah, in the back.
>> Audience Member:
So this is ICESat-2.
What's the difference
between it and ICESat-1?
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: Question
was, this is ICESat-2.
What's the difference
between it and ICESat-1.
Whole bunch of good stuff.
So ICESat-1 was on
orbit from 2003 to 2009.
It was a single beam altimeter,
so it just had one spot.
And its spot was pretty big.
It was about 70 meters
in diameter.
That laser fired about
40 times a second,
so you'd get a footprint,
70 meter footprint
about every 150 meters
along track.
So you'd get one giant spot.
Another 100 meters later,
you'd get another giant spot.
And so for sea ice that
was really difficult to use
because we couldn't detect
those individual leads
that are sometimes a lot
smaller than 70 meters.
And for ice sheets,
what would happen is
with the big footprints
and the single track,
we had a hard time
correcting for slope effects.
So imagine if this room wasn't
flat, but it was tilted,
and you're ranging to
this tilted surface,
and you're getting an average
measurement over that slope.
It was pretty hard to tease
out what's just an effect
of the surface slope and what's
an effect of elevation change.
That map of Greenland
I showed at the outset
that had the color
codes along the edges,
showing that there were changes
at the edges, we were able
to detect those changes
because they were on the order
of like, 10 meters a year.
They were pretty big differences
from each time ICESat
would go pass.
But with ICESat-2, we'll
have these six beams
that will let us take care
of those slope effects.
They'll let us find those
leads much easier in sea ice,
and should give us a
way more refined picture
of how things are changing.
But we learned a ton from
the first ICESat mission
that really went into
designing ICESat-2.
Yeah?
>> Audience Member:
[inaudible] the photons
that are transmitted
and make it back?
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: The question
was what percent of the photons
that are transmitted
make it back?
To round it off to the first
ten significant figures, zero.
[laughter] So we send out
about 300 trillion photons
in each pulse, and we
get about one back.
So it's about 1 part
in 300 trillion.
So it's -- yeah,
you might say, oh!
Well, all those wasted
photons are going for nothing.
[laughter] Which is true.
But what happens is
the beam spreads.
There's some beam
divergence to it.
And so the beam gets larger
and larger, it comes down.
It's 17 meters when
it hits the earth.
The earth doesn't reflect all
of the light back towards you.
Some of the light's
going to go left or right
or forward or backward.
Clouds scatter a
lot of it, as well.
And our field of view
up in space is an 80
centimeter diameter telescope.
So the field of view on the
ground is about 45 meters.
So we're only detecting photons
that essentially go straight
down and straight back again.
A little to the left,
a little to the right,
and we'll never see them.
But yeah, most of
those are lost.
Yeah, way in the back.
>> Audience Member: If you're
typically getting one or two
or three photons counted,
how many do you get
on the corner cubes?
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: Yeah.
So those corner cubes,
we don't know yet.
I've poked around a little bit
in the data looking for them,
but it's kind of a
needle in a haystack.
Our geolocation, if you will,
how precisely we can assign
a latitude, a longitude,
and a height, we're sort of on
version 1.1 of that algorithm,
and we keep tuning it.
So I haven't found
any data for it yet.
We think they'll be on the
order of about 20 or 25.
So it should look,
like, really bright,
compared to everything
around it.
And I put them up on poles that
were anywhere between a meter
to two meters above the surface.
So if you're zoomed
in far enough,
you should see the flat ground,
and then this super bright thing
two meters above the surface.
And that'll be the corner cube.
Yeah. Yeah?
>> Audience Member: You made a
very brief allusion to forestry.
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: Yes.
>> Audience Member: And from
a climate change perspective,
forest loss is probably
pretty --
in the same order of
magnitude as ice loss.
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: Yeah.
>> Audience Member: Is there
any formal process put in place
to have [inaudible] forests
management people look
at this data?
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: Yeah,
we actually do have a data
product design that's the --
we call it vegetation
canopy height.
So we have algorithms in
place from simulated data
to detect the ground below
the canopy, if we can,
and then the top of the canopy
and take that difference.
And that should let terrestrial
ecology folks get at biomass
of forests in different places.
We're not designed to do super
well at that measurement.
And the limitation
for us is two-fold.
One, if the canopy is really,
really dense, like you might get
in Brazil, some triple
canopy rainforests,
we just won't get any
photons down through
to the ground and back again.
So we'll measure
the top super well,
but we won't know
where the ground is.
On the other end of the
spectrum is a lone tree
out in a field somewhere,
you know?
And the canopy isn't
dense enough,
you don't get enough
data to say, all right,
here's a reliable measurement
of what the tree height is.
We'll get the ground
super well in that case,
but not the tree height.
So there's a sweet
spot for us of forests
like a deciduous forests,
we should do just fine.
And then building up data
through time, leaf on, leaf off,
maybe get a good measurement
of when the leaves
are on, of the top.
You get a better measurement of
the ground when leaves are off.
You put those two together,
now you're in business.
>> Audience Member:
Yeah, and then also,
from a climate change
perspective,
is the aggregate loss of
course, is crucially important
and it looks like that data
ought to be able to help them.
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: Yeah.
It -- [inaudible] absolutely.
And we do have a couple of
terrestrial ecology folks
on our science team that are
working towards exactly that.
We didn't know how well we
would do over forests for them,
because we're not
really optimized for it.
It's the wrong wavelength
and a few other differences
that they'd prefer.
But it's there and
it's not going
to be perfect, but
it'll be helpful.
Yeah?
>> Audience Member: Are
you able to get any data
on the changes of
the permafrost?
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: The question
was, are we able to get data
on changes in the permafrost?
Yeah, we certainly should.
Lots of areas, permafrost
is melting.
And what you see when that
permafrost is two things,
the surface goes down because
the ice that's in there melts
and returns to the water
table or to the ocean.
And two, you get ponding.
So we'll be able to
measure the heights
of those water bodies
pretty well.
We'll be able to tell when
something has gone from wet
to dry or dry to wet,
in the case of melting.
We don't have a data product
specifically for permafrost,
but we have one person on
the team who's interested
in that aspect, and that's
kind of his main focus,
is trying to measure
permafrost changes.
So we think we should be able to
do something for them, as well.
Yeah, in the back?
>> Audience Member: Why are
you guys using green light
and not a different --
>> Dr. Tom Neumann:
Different wavelength?
>> Audience Member:
What's the reasoning?
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: Yeah.
So the question is, why do
we use green light as opposed
to any other wavelength.
The first ICESat
used infrared light.
It turns out infrared
lasers are more efficient
at taking electrical energy
and turning it into light,
which is a consideration.
We ended up choosing green
to optimize the overall energy
efficiency of the whole design.
So when you're making
green laser light,
you're essentially
taking infrared light
and doubling its frequency
and you have a loss there,
as well, a pretty big one.
But on the detection side,
the detectors in the green are
about 15% efficient, whereas
the detectors in infrared, A,
weren't space qualified
yet, and B,
were about a half
of 1% efficient.
So we got about an order
of magnitude or two better
on the detection side,
even though we had this
penalty on the transmit side.
But you put those two together,
and it made green a
better choice for us.
Yeah?
>> Audience Member: The
National Weather Service uses
about 8,000 volunteers
to measure snow depth.
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: Yeah.
>> Audience Member: What's
the implications of this
for that measurement
of snow depth?
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: Yeah.
So the question was the National
-- National Weather Service?
Yeah. Uses volunteers to measure
snow depth all over the place.
What can ICESat-2 do for them?
It's a good question.
So we have our six beams.
They repeat every 91 days, so
we should go through a place
like Wisconsin, where
I'm from, in the summer,
and you get a good measurement
of the surface without
snow on it.
And then we come through 91 days
later, maybe it's October yes,
it already started
snowing there.
So if you're there after a
snowfall, you should be able
to take those two
elevation measurements,
take the difference,
and get the snow depth.
It's just a height,
and as I understand it,
what a lot of their interested
in is snow water equivalent,
how much water is in there.
But at least getting that height
difference between snow on
and snow off should
be useful for them.
There's a group called -- ooh,
their mission is called SnowX
and they're working
to come up with a way
to measure snow water
equivalent from space
for about a decade from now.
So they're just at
the beginning.
So they're super interested
in our data to get a map
of what snow depth is like.
A place like Wisconsin,
it's relatively easy
because it's farm fields,
it's relatively flat.
A place like the Rocky
Mountains or Sierra Nevada,
where there's steep slopes,
is going to be a lot harder
because you're pointing and
your geolocation have to be
that much better to know if you
were -- on some steep slope,
to know if you were here or you
were here, because you'd say,
okay, this snow pack is one
meter or it's ten meters.
Because just because that slope
of that ground is so severe.
Yeah. We're not optimized
for it, but we should be able
to help there, as well.
At least in some circumstances.
Cool. Anything else?
>> Stephanie Marcus: Okay.
Well, thank you for coming.
>> Dr. Tom Neumann: Awesome.
Thanks very much.
[ Applause ]